and tonight democrats and the media mob
once again they are in their
typical psychotic state of mania and
hysteria
all because president trump dared to
consult
with his doctors make his choice
i thought we were pro-choice talk to his
health care professionals
and take hydroxychloroquine as a
preventative measure
against covert 19. we're going to show
you the worst of the worst
and by the way we will help educate dr
joyless behar
dr liberal joe and all the other psycho
conspiracy theorists over at msdnc
but now it is day 65 of
joe biden hiding in his own basement
mumbling incoherent thoughts on his
disastrous podcast
so the question is will joe
ever brave the real world again hi joe
how are you joe doing podcasts for
getting his on camera
you know that guy anyway we'll have a
full report tonight
but our top story what did barack know
what did joe know and when did they know
it
because on january 20th 2017 donald
trump was being inaugurated
as the 45th president of the united
states on the very same day in the final
hours of the obama administration
susan rice remember her she was the
white house
in the white house crafting an email
from susan rice to susan rice
herself in a very unusual letter rice
was memorializing a meeting that took
place
15 days earlier when her former boss
barack
gathered all of his top intel law
enforcement officials together in the
oval office
in that meeting brennan clapper comey
biden yates rice all there all present
in the oval office and they were
discussing a russian collusion in the
2016 election
too bad they didn't know about and talk
about hillary clinton's bought and paid
for russian disinformation
dossier that was used the real russia
interference
and according to rice's email quote
president
obama began the conversation by
stressing
his continued commitment to ensuring
that every
aspect of this issue is handled by the
intelligence and law enforcement
communities
by the book okay she continued
he reiterated our law enforcement team
needs to proceed as it normally would
by the book and in a paragraph just
declassified by acting dni
director rick cornell susan rice wrote
quote
director comey affirmed that he is
proceeding
by the book now why would susan rice
well we know what a pathological liar
she is why did she feel the need to
write
by the book three times uh
on the last day they're in the white
house in relation to
a 15-day old meeting why did she do it
on the final day
oh let me go back i forgot to
memorialize that meeting from 15 days
ago
now according to the same email rice
wrote that comey had
no indication that incoming security
adviser general flynn
had passed on any classified material to
his future russian counterpart
as a matter of fact we now know that
they had no evidence
at all as of january 4th it was struck
in comey that reopened it
but by the way the level of
communication comey said was unusual
in reality what was particularly unusual
was comey's aggressive persecution
of general flynn now after that
so-called by the book meeting obama
pulled sally yates and james comey aside
why to discuss flynn now according to
the recently released testimony from
sally yates
this is from the house intel committee
that the corrupt congenital cowardly
you know adam schiff was hiding a former
deputy a.g
she admits she was shocked to learn on
january 5th
that barack hussein obama the president
had intimate details of flynn's wiretap
phone calls
does that seem uh by the book to you
what about fbi leadership demanding that
the flynn case be reopened
just the day before january 4 2020
after its investigation found no
evidence of wrongdoing
one other fact about january 5th the
chief of staff of barack obama that guy
was unmasking flynn dennis mcdonough
coincidence and eight days before they
left the
oval office and donald trump was
inaugurated then joe biden who said on
day one of this
last week he didn't know anything about
unmasking we found out he was one of the
unmaskers
what about comey sending the agents as
he admits and brags about on tape
to ambush general flynn a 33-year
veteran
uh four days into the trump
administration something he'd never do
or get away with in any other
administration
and what about before meeting with those
fbi agents
well general flynn called andrew mccabe
deputy fbi
uh guy and asked him do i need my lawyer
and what about the agent
who asked quote what is our goal with
general flynn is it
get him to tell the truth an admission
or to get him to lie
so we can prosecute him or get him fired
is that policy by the book for the fbi
get
somebody to lie set a perjury trap
ambush a 33-year veteran tell him he
doesn't need an attorney when he damn
well needed one
yeah none of that's by the book what
about the text from lisa page
president obama wants to know everything
that we're doing they want to be kept
abreast of this
the white house does what about struck's
insurance
insurance policy in the unlikely event
that donald trump wins
now fbi director ray are you comfortable
with any of this
are you because will you ever hold
anyone accountable do you director ray
care about what is
abuse of power and corruption that took
place
at the world's premier law enforcement
agency
the one of which you are now the
director
in other words director ray are you
going to do anything to restore the
reputation
of this the world's premier law
enforcement institution or
are you going to sweep it under the rug
be an institutionalist be afraid to rock
the boat
and maybe you even want to protect your
friends and and you don't want to go
there
well for the sake of the 99 of great
agents
by the way it's my fbi pin right there
maybe you should do the right thing for
the country
for the rule of law for the justice
department for the fbi
and get to the bottom of it and if
you're not up to the job maybe you
should tell president trump
i'm just not up to this job i don't want
to do the heavy lifting here
and maybe we can make general flynn the
new director of the fbi
now to add insult to injury the judge
presiding over flynn's case
there's judge emmett sullivan now he did
a great job in ted stevens case
i don't know what's gotten into him he
seems pretty well determined though to
drag the general through the mud
all over again the ones pretty much
accusing him of treason
and to spoke both the prosecution and
the defense agreeing to drop
all the charges and end this case judge
sullivan
sullivan has now invited liberal groups
to submit their
amicus priests amicus briefs and argue
in favor of continuing flynn's
persecution
now breaking today flynn attorney sidney
powell
she fired what is an emergency appeal to
remove
judge sullivan from this case he needs
to go
she's rightly arguing the judge is
abusing his power
particularly since the judge previously
accused flynn
of being a traitor to the u.s nice way
to treat people
now sadly tonight what happened to
general flynn as horrible as it is
that's only the tip of the iceberg
now senator lindsey graham following on
the heels of what devin nunes said and
what trey gowdy said
senator lindsey graham is now demanding
unmasking records surrounding members of
the trump campaign
the trump white house and yes even the
president's family
as trey gowdy and devin nunes have told
us happened
now senator graham also just announced
that the senate judiciary committee
they will begin their hearings on june
the third on whether or not
to subpoena comey well they said they
would subpoena comey mccabe
strzok page loretta lynch sally yates
brennan clapper rice rod rosenstein
and many others so buckle up all of you
deep state
saboteurs that are there this will be
summer camp with your lawyers you're
gonna have to spend a lot of time with
them in air-conditioned offices
hope you hope you like a lot of coffee
now soon the corrupt bureaucrats who
waged a months-long counter intel
campaign against the trump campaign
and the trump transition team then two
years of the trump presidency
they will likely be forced to answer
questions under oath
remember by the way lying under oath is
a very serious crime they're the ones
that tell us that
and by the way all those that abuse
power you must be held accountable
if roger stone let's see paul manafort
michael cohen
uh papadopoulos and general flynn
they're all going to get
set up and you know hung out to dry on
lying to congress and they get 29 guys
in tactical gear
rating their house pre-dawn raids with
cnn cameras in one case no cnn cameras
in the other
uh then you deserve the same treatment
and while graham barr
durham and so many others focus on the
biggest abuse of power scandal in
history
democrats are just trying to revive
their impeachment quest
now they just told the u.s supreme court
that they needed the full
unredacted mueller report why because
their impeachment investigation
is still underway hang on a second i
thought that the house did the
impeachment
the senate held the trial and the
president was found not guilty
by a long shot so they're trying to
argue to the u.s supreme court
that that impeachment is still ongoing
okay
it's over but they're also signaling
they want to never stop impeachments
mark my words the witch hunt will never
stop
and by the way in 178 days you get to
decide